[موسيقى]
تقدر اداره التجاره الدوليه في الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان قرابه 70% من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اي نحو 41 مليون هكتار هي
اراضي زراعيه او تصلح للزراعه وتعد
الصادرات الزراعيه مصدر الدخل الاهم
للاقتصاد الاوكراني
خيرسون وغيرها من المناطق التي باتت تحت
السيطره الروسيه الكليه او الجزئيه كانت
تسمى سله غذاء اوكرانيا بوصفها مناطق
رئيسيه لزراعه الحبوب قبل الحرب عام 2021
صنفت اوكرانيا خامس مصدر للحبوب في العالم
بحجم صادرات كلي قارب 50 مليون طن ورابع
مصدر للقمح بمعدل سبعه ملايين طن شهريا
فقرابه 42% من الانتاج العالمي من زيت
بذور دوار الشمس ياتي من اوكرانيا
و16% من انتاج العالم من الذره وقرابه
تسعه في المئه من انتاج القمح
وتصدر اوكرانيا قبل الحرب 30% من الحبوب
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي ونحو اربعين في
المئه الى افريقيا
وثلاثين في المئه الى اسيا
بيانات رسميه اوكرانيه في الفتره التي
سبقت اندلاع الحرب اشارت الى ان عام
2001 2021 سجل معدل صادرات من الحبوب بنحو
ثمانيه واربعين مليون طن بينما وصلت كميات
الحصاد الى قرابه 86 مليون طن من الحبوب
في رقم قياسي غير مسبوق اما خلال العام
الاول من حرب روسيا فانخفض الانتاج بشكل
دراماتيكي الى 53 مليون طن مع توسع رقعه
الاعمال الحربيه في المناطق الشرقيه
والشماليه والجنوبيه من البلاد
تفاقمت اثر ذلك ازمه غذاء عالميه فاتت
اتفاق البحر الاسود الذي رعته الامم
المتحده
وضمنته تركيا في محاوله لاستئناف التصدير
احتلت الصين المرتبه الاولى باستيراد
قرابه ثمانيه ملايين طن من الصادرات
الزراعيه تليها اسبانيا بسته ملايين ثم
تركيا باكثر من ثلاثه ملايين طن في
ايطاليا وهولندا بنحو مليونييتون لتكون
الدول الاوروبيه اغلبيه الدول المستورده
بحسب وزاره الزراعه الامريكيه اما ابرز
الصادرات وفق الاتفاق فهي الذره مستحوذه
على 51% من مجمل ما تم نقله مقابل
27% للقمح واحد عشر في المئه لدوار الشمس
وتوزعت العشرات في المئه المتبقيه على عدد
من السلع الزراعيه الاخرى
[موسيقى]